[音楽]
me
goo ん
ちょび
ええええええ
こんにちははじめ社長ですちょっと土日なので海にちらほらと人が多いのでちょっと
恥ずかしいですというわけでこちら今ちょっと膨らませてるんですけども
透明なテントというものを昔動画で使いました
外に置いといたら雑感色がなんか大目じゃなくなっちゃったんですけどもいつメンは
透明で今回何をしようグッズ言いますと
変まり黙ってあるじゃないですかめちゃくちゃ色が出る季ぶりだ街が売ってたんですよ
海外から時入れましたこんなんです上物なんか見た目がヤバイ相撲めちゃめちゃ
毒々しい感じになってるんですけども1000円の周りでこんな煙タグわけにもいか
なかったんで人の少ない海でちょっと行け煙たいてみようと思います
じゃあ高は3つなんだけど大丈夫で安定核に安静から2本脚休憩できません
でどうしようお前れなんかこうや行動のさあ支援場所みたいには何かじゃないですよ
大丈夫よねちょっとだけやってみます
[音楽]
ん
ねっ8番4紫だ紫紫
で一瞬で終わったんだけどおかしいよ
[音楽]
噂聞かせくださドクドクしいや poison poison
結構出るならん割としっかり出てますね
とうとうすぎな映像が出ているのではないでしょうかこの世のものとは思えん暗黒的な
演出がすごいです皆さん心配せずにコナへメリー連行に害はないらしいです分かりませ
んけどと書いてありましたこうやって見てもらったらを買ってもですけども削りが風と
どんどん移動していくんですよ
これは全て無くなっちゃうそこで私考えましたケメ子が逃げるのであれば逃さなければ
いい
あっはーなー息が忘れちまったなぜか忘れたんですけどもなんかし5種類ぐらい色が
出るキャリアを準備したんでこちらの王命なテントの出番でございます彼の10度だっ
たら色が入ってて見えないんですけども透明なテントだったらこの中で煙玉の色を
起こすと攻める4
逃すことなくこのテントの中に密封しで切れます
煙の色を逃すことなくこのテントの中にずっと密閉することができます
さらに透明なので動きがうわっからもういろんな色の権利なも今からこの中でも休んで
ずさんさが残る限り思えると思うんですよいろんな煙の色が降赤や紫やピンからキー目
が多分でますと出て色がこの中でこう言うにゃうにゃ得
映像しているその色がどうなるのか今日は楽しみですねーそれで早速やっていきました
ぜひじゃあさっそく中に入れていこうと思いましたバッチリ酸素はずっと打ってる
燃焼が溜まることは基本的なないと思います
rar
大丈夫久々にいいしましたその a 米です目はさーん
敗退するいいねぇ
政党から好天のでズバーン言わせたから見ている
[音楽]
あああああなんだよっては発足しかけていきます
ale
den o
ああああああ
[音楽]
ねやってまたでか時間
反対にず食わずで汚いと思ってる
全然綺麗だーええっっ
俺もたサ科学ネットここなんで音が若いっ
多分6ですもう原因としては多分70分も置いてました
なんだか耳寸前日中がさぁさぁ十分事足りてるんですけども本土のケムリ玉の炎色反応
を起こす場所が狭すぎて版の中に買って全部ぶち込んでたんでうまいこと酸素が
行き届かなくてきれいに煙が出なかったという可能性はありますなので by これ
酸素を送り込む機会なんですけども
ここからこそアウト
ブーバーしっかりと綺麗な子を起こすことを大字赤っぽい
いきます
ん
いけませんけどこれうまいことを待って落ち着けもう一度横乳よ
[音楽]
まあ健康に害はないことですやっぱりして野菜も出てるんじゃないけど
いきました未だん
bde ああああ
ゴーストバスターズですめっちゃ可愛いけど言われています
ファイターすげー
だほいすべてを取り込めれさんっぽい
ああ言ってめちゃいっ
すごいはすごくな n 子の子
入った
別これ感じいい感じいい感じいい感じ
[音楽]
いる時のパーティダメってやばいよねバーイれた5位
me
思ってる色々出る懸命だまぁ全部位で終わりました離して何色になっているでしょうか
見てきます
きたねー
pou dou dou
同様見てくれてありがとうございましたこちらの映像は実際に煙をテントに入れている
時の中の映像です見てもらったのは彼のように煙の色がちゃんと反映されているのが
分かりますねしっかり色が店土の中で残ってたんで色々混ざった結果
このイブでしたちゃんと後片付けして帰りました油のみんな真似しないでね